[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by bellway
and i'm gonna be taking you behind the
scenes to share my
insanely early and very geeky bedtime
routine
but first let me tell you about today's
sponsor belleway i've spoken about the
importance of
good digestive health many times on this
channel before
since our gut plays a role in literally
every other system in our body from our
immune system
heart brain skin nails you name it
if our digestive system is disturbed
there's a risk that
everything else won't work optimally
either
my long-term followers also know that i
am low-key
obsessed with getting my fiber not only
for good digestion
but also to help build those satiating
snacks
and meals with the hunger crushing combo
in mind
but let's be real while a lot of the
influencers that you see in your view
are getting more than their
fair share of fiber most people that i
see in real life
aren't getting anywhere near enough so
if you're struggling to hit your 25 to
38 grams of fiber a day you may want to
consider a third party tested fiber
supplement
like bellway so belway is a psyllium
fiber supplement that helps to keep you
regular without making you rush to the
washroom
it's appropriate for a wide range of
dietary restrictions like vegan
gluten-free and even keto for whom
getting enough fiber
can be an extra challenge and it's
flavored with
real fruit so that it actually tastes
really good you can mix it into
your water or a smoothie and take it
every day if you want
or just on those occasions when you need
a little help meeting your needs like
maybe you're away from home
or you're vacationing etc so if you want
to give belleway a try
you can use my code below to get 20 off
of your
first order also you can pause the
screen and check out my disclaimer here
including a reminder that my bedtime
routine is not
i repeat not to serve as a suggestion
on what to do or what is healthy to do
honestly some of my habits are kind of
messed up thanks to my covet and baby
related insomnia
but since you all enjoyed my insane 4am
morning routine so much
and i got countless questions about what
time i had to go to bed
to accommodate that early wake-up call i
wanted to give you a
real authentic look at how i spend
the hours after dinner let me get you up
to speed
it's 6 p.m and we have just finished our
family dinner
yes i have dinner at a very geriatric 5
30 p.m
welcome to parenthood folks i don't know
how everyone else is feeling after being
locked up for so long but
i genuinely am concerned that when kova
does go away
and life somewhat returns to normal that
i'm never going to have
like the confidence to go out for a 7 30
p.m
dinner reservation again a little dinner
dancing drinks
you said you didn't have plans
that's what you said my social anxiety
related to my sleep
and my evening routine is pretty intense
but anyways back to said routine so i
basically
tidy up the kitchen doing a mediocre job
at best
cleaning is not my forte this sink is
filthy
my husband can definitely attest to that
as i am much more proficient
at making a mess then cleaning it up
but i do try to at least make sure that
there isn't any leftover food on the
table for poppy to eat
while my husband takes both kids
upstairs
[Music]
poppy did you eat
now before heading upstairs myself i pop
oh's bottle of pumped milk
in the bottle warmer i used to
exclusively breastfeed before bed
but i was finding that like most women
my supply is naturally lowest
at this time of night and i was just
concerned that oh just wasn't able to
get enough
milk to get them through a whole 12-hour
stretch
so now my hubby helps me out a little
bit by giving him a
bottle of pumped milk before i nurse
then i set out the kids pjs so
these ones are from little sleepies they
are the only pjs that i buy
they're super comfy and stretchy and
they're really great if you got really
super long kiddos like i do
where they tend to outgrow the length
before the width of anything
so this pattern is what he calls feedy
moons
he used to wear the two-piece pjs until
he saw that oh got one
like a one-piece zippy and then i had to
buy e a whole new
bedtime wardrobe to match so if this is
the worst
of sibling rivalry that i'm gonna get
i'm okay with that
the boys bathe together right now
because your girl does not
have the bandwidth to do everything
twice ain't nobody got time for that
thank you very much that means a little
bath c for o
and he just kind of roams free range
style
with every random toy that we own and
yes that is a manual silicone breast
pump which has become
one of his favorites for some strange
but not surprising reason
what in the ass honestly nothing in
parenthood surprises me anymore
but it is funny watching him suction it
to himself and pretend to pump
like mama so while my hubby gets the
kids into the bath
i take like two minutes to wash the day
off my face
right now i'm using sturm which is a
really nice light exfoliant face wash
i find it is really key for days that
i'm wearing a lot of makeup since
i get a lot of dry skin so it's nice to
kind of slough that off i then take off
my makeup with some basic drugstore
brand i think it's a neutrogena
does the trick and then i use the
skinceuticals
redness neutralizing serum which i kind
of got suckered into buying in some
cosmetic consultation but honestly i'm
not mad about it
and while i'm not personally sold in it
i'm using reversals
moisturizer for redness i don't think
it's helped my redness to be honest
but i'm just trying to use it up before
i buy something new
so this is when my hubby and i do a
little tag team action
i'll tell you i got to come in oh here
we go
here's the answers here's the answers a
hard time by the rock
our tag is slapping and no i was not
going to film the bath and dressing
stages of our night
but my hubs takes o gets him lotioned up
and into his pjs
and then he takes him downstairs to try
to coerce him into taking
that bottle of pumped milk it is kind of
a stealthy
ninja operation because if o sees me
hears me smells me or like
psychically senses that i am too close
by
he will not take the damn bottle
so we basically need to be as far away
from each other as possible
meanwhile i dress e and i give him a
little bedtime snack
maybe some peanut butter on toast or
some crackers and cheese
and we listen to a story from kids short
stories
podcast this is honestly the best thing
ever because sometimes
you're just too tired at the end of the
day to
muscle through a heavy read like dr
seuss i
am indeed a cat and this indeed
is a hat am i right anyways once o
finishes his bottle
my husband and i switch places hubs
takes e to read a book and brushes teeth
if you want to know what that looks like
here is some actual
live footage of that in action
so yeah i am happy that that's not my
task but i take o to breastfeed which is
really just like a top up to make sure
that he's full after his bottle
and it's also just nice cuddle time for
him and i
and then we attempt to read a few books
which is
often a struggle with a wobbly tired
babe but some of my
favorites for newborns in case you're
looking for some good new reads
any of the jelly cat books like if i
were a bunny or if i were a dog or if i
were a polar bear
got them all also the that's not my
blank books that's not my narwhal that's
not my unicorn or whatever
runaway bunny which i cry reading
every time i don't know what it is about
bunnies but it's uh
gets me and also the very hungry
caterpillar
anyways i pop him into his crib and sing
him a little song
i don't actually know what this song is
called but
my nanny used to sing e something
similar like but
the tune had filipino words to it
[Music]
so i just kind of picked up the general
tune and i think i adapted it
a little bit over time so i don't know i
guess it's my own version of a lullaby
now
and by the way if you're wondering what
is that god-awful noise in the
background
that my friends is what we call the
soundtrack of parenthood
white noise you can walk through any
room or any floor of my house
and you will hear that on full blast
okay kids down
oh is working himself out to try to get
himself to sleep i get downstairs to
pump
on the one hand this is like my least
favorite part of my day
pumping but on the other hand it means
that
my day is over and it's pretty much time
to go to bed
so it's toss toss-up
do i love it do i hate it bit about
folks but it's what you gotta do
it means that maybe one day
one day when i can leave the house
someone can feed my kid for me
that's the hope i'm holding out for that
might be wishful thinking
i really only pump twice a day once
before bed to fully empty
and then once in the middle of the night
to maintain my supply
and also to freeze some milk for my boys
and for others
since giving birth i've donated about 2
000 ounces of breast milk to moms in my
community
and that feels like such a mitzvah for
me since
i honestly sacrificed everything i had
to produce enough milk in the early days
with e
and he was still hungry for war so i
just feel like being a mom
a new mom is so stressful especially in
a pandemic
so if i can help take away one little
burden for a few moms in need
it is totally worth me getting up in the
middle of the night for
i don't know a few more months or
whatever i also
have my own little bedtime snack now
honestly i go to bed so early
but i have a long night ahead and
what i find is that no matter what when
i wake up to pump
i'm hungry so i really need to have a
satisfying snack before bed
pretty much as much as i can eat without
it causing the opposite problem
and triggering digestive issues tonight
i did like a big bowl
of full fat greek yogurt with some
cereal for crunch and some blueberries
i like that combo plus i also want
something a little something sweet
before bed too
so i capped things off with a fudgical
bar
for fun and now we brush our teeth so
many of you
pointed out in my morning routine video
that i was brushing
incorrectly with my electric brush sorry
uh
apparently there's no need to move it
around like you would a manual brush
when the rotating bristles do
all that work for you amazing
because i'm lazy and my wrist is
that was gonna be a sex joke that's what
she said but i'm a parent with two
babies
that would be a lie so anyways no i
won't be moving my electric brush around
anymore
thank you very much but also i don't
floss every day
i wish i could say i've lost every day
but again
lazy tired parent no
i need those extra three flossing
minutes
to like lay in bed and not sleep
mommy mommy mama
mama next quick trigger warning i'm
about to take my contacts out which
let's be real
i don't know i fall asleep in more often
than i care to admit
and the sexiest part of my bedtime
routine
my removable retainer and mouth guard
combo
yes please
the dendi says i am the only adult that
she knows who still wears her removable
retainer from her braces days
but i don't want those teeth to move and
i had to get a mouth guard for the first
time in my life just a few months ago
because kovit had me like grinding my
teeth in
anxiety and stress and apparently sexy
mouth guards are
on trend right now as my dentist said
that sales are
on the rise from this so i'm not alone
anyway supplements come next so my
supplement regimen
changes all the time just based on my
needs and stages of life
right now before bed i'm taking
sunflower lecithin to prevent clogged
ducts
vitamin d3 omega-3 prenatal vitamins
still
and l-glutamine for digestion now a
quick reminder that these supplements
are
very specific to me and my needs i get
regular blood work done so i know
exactly what i need to take more of
and how much i need to take always speak
to your doctor or dietitian about your
unique needs
remember also that too much of a
specific nutrient can
also be a problem so please do not
self-diagnose or
self-prescribe always speak to a
dietician about your supplement needs
i also take a scoop of magnesium calm
just to help support my sleep and
relaxation which
we know i need help with and a scoop of
belways
psyllium fiber so psyllium is actually
fodmap friendly
and often recommended for ibs so i have
found it to be helpful for keeping
things
on track especially since i've had to
mindfully reduce
a lot of my higher fiber staples in my
diet
then i get myself to bed and i really
start my sleep hygiene routine
now i've talked about my insomnia a lot
in the past
and while it is miles better than it was
back in 2019
when i was doing ivf and suffering from
pregnancy
loss it's not perfect i have good nights
and
not so good nights a lot of which can
depend on what happened
during the day but i start things off
with a little spritz of melatonin
which i don't know it's probably more
placebo at this point than anything
since i've likely built up some
tolerance to its effects at this point
then i basically read until my eyes
start to feel
droopy sometimes i even doze off for a
second i tend to try to read
kind of semi-boring non-work related
books usually
parenting and relationship advice fyi
in case you're wondering i like janet
lansbury's work but
i do kind of blend rye and montessori
methods myself in my parenting
because i find some of her techniques
feel i don't know a little unnatural to
me
but that's also okay since i'm like half
sleeping through reading it
so it's more of like a sleep tactic than
anything
it's also worth me noting that i get up
to pee like four times between
when i get into bed and when i actually
fall asleep which is probably more of
like a nervous anxiety habit than an
actual
need to go most nights these days when
i put my book down because my eyes are
droopy and i turn off the lights
i can pretty much go right to sleep
which is great but
sometimes i get in my head
and i lay there and i think what if i
don't sleep
how long have i been laying here uh if
it's been 20 minutes my therapist said i
should get out of bed so i don't poison
my bed
maybe i need to pee a little bit if i
don't go i'll just wake up again
maybe i'm a little bit hungry and i
should go have a snack oh now i'm
thirsty now i have to pee
blah blah blah blah blah so a few
nights of the week i end up having to
get up
and do something in another room
recently i've gotten into the annoying
habit of
walking on the treadmill and watching
some light tv to kind of like
reset my anxious brain this is not like
a hit session
this is a pretty leisurely slow walk but
i
almost see it as like a walking
meditation because sometimes if i'm
too still as i am in my bed my mind just
doesn't slow down
so i see it as being better to move my
body
so that my mind can get to rest this is
also not the best time for like my
beloved true crime shows i've made that
mistake in the past and it has haunted
me as i tried to get back to sleep
i try to keep it really light and boring
with like jeopardy
or wheel of fortune something that feels
kind of geriatric
which i guess reminds me of sleep sorry
grams
so after doing like 30 to 60 minutes of
something like that
i'm usually calm enough to try again and
usually
i am able to fall asleep but then i do
have to get up at like 1 30 in the
morning to pump
and usually i can fall back asleep but
it is
also short-lived if i do because well
you guys know
i'm an early bird yep you read that
right
4am partially by obligation partially by
choice but i mean
i don't know if i had my way i would
love to sleep until six
love it please i can't wait for that day
when i can sleep until six because maybe
my my boys are teens and they are asleep
until 10
a.m i am going to love that but that's
it i bet you expected me to give you
this super wellness wooy evening routine
filled with acts of self-care like
meditation
and journaling and bubble baths and face
masks but
i'm trying to keep it real here i am
generally so exhausted just juggling
everything on my plate
and my cup feels so perpetually empty
that
i kind of just have tunnel vision on
just getting myself to sleep
so i can't even really say something
reassuring like this is just what works
for me
because if i had it my way this probably
wouldn't be
my evening routine this is a routine of
a woman who is
kind of burnt out and also existing in
survival mode i know i have so many
privileges and i'm
so blessed in so many ways but i will
say that the past few years between
infertility and pregnancy postpartum
infertility
pregnancy postpartum and covid hasn't
been so great for my sleep
so here i am just really doing the best
damn job that i can
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
belleway for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what vlog content you want to see next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great vlog content like
this
check out the link right here
you